welcome to the 3 i'm playing gb ray orgy
Bray again yeah let's go 45 and yeah
this is some a rail line against the
sriman it's not really easy to anything
wow this is very very modest okay um how
to how to set up pieces him is going to
give this check here with the king okay
check so I won't want to control him
Knight see form takes here yeah of
course can can do that should I should I
be ambitious here not sure b5 the move
that I'm thinking about now come on keep
it simple
check
they are they're simply not much going
on you will probably take all know d6 at
some point can I can play another 6 hmm
Oh Bishop e6
maybe this is a half can take and play a
form hmm I forgot that the rook is still
only 1 a 1 yeah this was too quick yeah
very obviously now he has got his got
simple I within down
check
who
hmm yeah
yeah this was great I was almost falling
asleep here and didn't pay any attention
to anything Wow if you just give this
check here and rook t8 what what exactly
am i playing then bishop CA had married
Knight f6 was what I intended to do but
look here what the crappy position what
the heck
loop system
yeah ffuck I have you seen a move I know
Brooksie 796 but I didn't really see ya
check was hoping for that maybe to hang
on a bit here and this my dad gave us is
lost okay I didn't have a move I simply
simply gave him the game with this
lowering a 4 monsters dad always hurts
if the opponent is playing so very
unambitious Lee but you can easily fall
asleep and don't pay any attention by
guided so this isn't even so easy now I
get 36
yeah white is winning of course but
still still he needs to play some moves
if it goes if i go here yeah yeah I can
I can just sit and wait here see how is
going to make some progress
hmm what the heck could have just taken
I wasn't really paying any attention aha
now he's tried for c5
hmm
it's no trick or anything no not really
94 stadium but ok but it is lost anyway
um we can even even do that him yeah
okay come on black resigned yeah you
really are sent me to sleep with this
was a setup dumb jock it wasn't it
wasn't so easy yeah this was just just
bad and he can play 95 this is even
better well really a crap game I mean ok
this is this is perfectly alright but
here I need to I need to improve that
lame now probably him get the rook here
to 228 I mean what you did is just
unambitious it's not bad and just now
there should be six and in continuum
yeah this is what I need to do chatter
after that it's terrible and he punished
us nicely I'm just sitting in terrible
shape check now this is really a really
amazingly bad it's no absolutely no way
to defend alright thanks for watching